.
STATE MEDIA IN IRAN SAY TO THE
SUSPECTED ATTACKERS HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED BY SECURITY FORCES.
THE SEARCH CONTINUES FOR A
THIRD.
40 DAYS HAVE NOW PASSED SINCE
22-YEAR-OLD MAHSA AMINI DIED
WHILE BEING HELD BY THE
SO-CALLED EMERATI POLICE.
THOUSANDS GATHERED AMID TIGHT
SECURITY, AND ACROSS IRAN,
DEVERS ANGRY CLASHES BETWEEN
PROTESTERS AND SECURITY FORCES.
IN THE CAPITAL OF TEHRAN, TEAR
GAS AND --
IN IRAN'S KURDISTAN PROVINCE,
WHERE A MINUTE WAS FROM, A
TOTAL BLACKOUT OF THE INTERNET.
IN AN EXCLUSIVE INVESTIGATION,
CNN HAS LOOKED AT THE FINAL
HOURS OF IRANIAN TEENAGER --
WHO IS AMONG THE MANY
PROTESTERS ON THE STREETS AND
DAYS AFTER IMMEDIATE DEATH.
AFTER ANALYZING WHAT EMPATHY
VIDEOS OBTAINED BY CNN,
SPEAKING TO SIX EYEWITNESSES,
THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT SHE WAS
CHASED AND DETAINED BY POLICE
JUST A FEW HOURS BEFORE SHE
WENT MISSING.
CNN'S --
HERE'S THE REPORT.
>> NICO SHAKARAMI, THE
16-YEAR-OLD HAS BECOME ONE OF
THE MOST KNOWN FACES IN IRAN.
ON SEPTEMBER 20TH, NICO WAS A
HIGH-PROFILE FIGURE AT THE
PROTESTS, AND KNOWN PERSONALITY
ON SOCIAL MEDIA, SHE STOOD
CHANTING FOR THE CROWDS.
OFFICIALS SAY THAT WITHIN 24
HOURS, SHOULD BE THAT.
NIKKHAH JOINED A GROWING LIST
OF YOUNG WOMEN WHO HAD LOST
THEIR LIVES IN RECENT WEEKS, AS
PROTESTERS SWEPT IRAN, AND
AUTHORITIES WAIST A BY THE
CRACKDOWN AND RESPONSE.
THEY MADE A SERIES OF SHOOTING
CLAIMS, FOR SAYING THAT HER
DEATH HAD, QUOTE, NO CONNECTION
TO THE PROTESTS, BUT THAT SHE
WAS THROWN FROM A ROOF.
AND THEN ON WEDNESDAY, A NEW
CLAIM FROM THE JUDICIARY THAT
IT WAS TO SET.
ON THE BASIS OF OUR
INVESTIGATION USING OVER 50
VIDEOS FROM THAT NIGHT AND
SPEAKING TO THOSE WITH HER THAT
EVENING, CNN CAN REVEAL THAT
SOME OF HER FINAL HOURS WERE
SPENT AT THE PURPOSE, INCLUDING
EVIDENCE THAT SUGGESTS SHE WAS
CHASED AND DETAINED BY SECURITY
JUST A FEW HOURS BEFORE THE
STATE SAYS SHE DIED.
THE FIRST VIDEOS WE FOUND
NIKKHAH ON THE 20TH ARE HERE AT
7 PM.
AS PROTESTS THERE'S --
NICA COULD BE SEEN AT THE FRONT,
FORM --
EASILY RECOGNIZED, SHE WAS
BRAVE BUT EVEN FOR END, I
WITNESSES SAID.
AT THIS STAGE IN THE EVENING,
MICAH IS HERE, BY THE PARK.
AND THEN AS MORE OFFICERS
ARRIVE, WITNESSES SAY THAT
MICAH STARTS TO MOVE AWAY FROM
THEM, FIRST ALONG THE BOULEVARD
AND THEN DOWN THE STREET, WHERE
SHE IS SEEN MAKING A PHONE CALL
JUST BEFORE 8 PM.
AS IT GETS DARK, THE POLICE
CRACKDOWN INTENSIFIES, MOVING
INTO NICA'S NEW LOCATION.
EVIDENCE OF INJURY STARTS
EMERGING, AND PROTESTERS ARE
SEEN BEING DETAINED, APPARENTLY
BY PLAINCLOTHED OFFICERS.
ONE PERSON TOLD CNN THEY SAW
SECURITY FORCES HITTING WOMEN
AND PUTTING THEM IN PLEASE
FENCE.
IN THE MIDST OF A HEIGHTENED
VIOLENCE, CNN FOUND A VIDEO OF
NICA, STILL AT THE CENTER OF
THE PROTESTS, 8:37 PM, AND THE
LAST KNOWN VIDEO OF HER.
DON'T MOVE, DON'T MOVE, SHE
SHOUTS, AS SHE CATCHES BETWEEN
CARS TO HIDE FROM AUTHORITIES.
THE PERSON FILMING FROM THE CAR
TOLD CNN THAT SHORTLY
AFTERWARDS, NICK IT WAS TAKEN
BY SEVERAL LARGE BODY SECURITY
FORCES AND BUNDLED INTO A VAN.
BY THIS POINT IN THE EVENING,
POLICE WERE EVERYWHERE, VIDEOS
WE GEOLOCATED TO THE SCENE SHOW
POLICE TO THE SOUTH AND ALSO TO
THE NORTH OF NICA.
IT MEANS WHEN SHE WAS CROUCHING
IN TRAFFIC, SHE WAS COMPLETELY
SURROUNDED.
BY THE NEXT MORNING, SHE WOULD
BE THAT, ACCORDING TO THIS THAT
SIGNIFICANT, FIRST OBTAINED BY
BBC PERSIAN AND VERIFIED BY
CNN.
IT SHOWS SHE DIED FROM MULTIPLE
INJURIES CAUSED BY A HIT WITH A
HARD OBJECT, AND IT'S DATED
SEPTEMBER 21ST.
BUT NICK'S FAMILY WOULD NOT
LEARN OF HEARD THAT FOR ANOTHER
TEN DAYS.
MEANWHILE, BOTH BECAUSE MOTHER
AND ANNA HAVE SAID IN
INTERVIEWS THAT CREDIBLE
SOURCES TOLD HIM THAT FOR DAYS
DURING THAT WINTER, NICO WAS IN
CITIES CUSTODY.
THE RAIN AUTHORITIES RELEASED
THIS CCTV FOOTAGE, CLAIMING
THAT NIKA AT THE BIG TERM FROM
THE BUILDING, THAT ARE THAT
SOME.
NIGHT IN AN INCIDENT THEY SAY
WAS UNCONNECTED TO THE
PROTESTS.
THEY MADE NO CLAIM ABOUT WHO
ALLEGEDLY THREW HER, AND CNN
CANNOT VERIFY THAT THE PERSON
IS NIKA NOT THE DAY IT WAS
FILMED.
NIKA MOTHER HAS PUBLICLY
DISPUTED THE FOOTAGE SAYING
IT'S NOT OUR DAUGHTER.
AND IT'S HARD TO SQUARE THIS
CALM WALK WITH THE EVIDENCE WE
HAVE OF NIKA BEING CHASED BY
POLICE AND DETAINED A FEW HOURS
EARLIER.
IRANIAN OFFICIALS HAVE NOT
RESPONDED TO CNN'S INQUIRY
ABOUT WHETHER SHE WAS EVER IN
CUSTODY IN THE HOURS LEADING UP
TO HER DEATH.
WHAT IS CERTAIN THOUGH IS THAT
NIKA WAS A PROMINENT ACTIVIST
AT THE CENTER OF A POL